buenas noticias para la economía europea
Bruselas ha confirmado con sus
previsiones económicas lo que se parecía
atisbar este mismo año y es que la
eurozona será capaz de esquivar la
recesión este año según las previsiones
de la comisión europea la eurozona
crecerá un 1,1% este año entre las
economías que van a crecer está España
con un 1,9% seguida de Países Bajos
Francia e Italia pero sin embargo
Alemania motor de la economía europea
sin embargo mantiene una previsión de
crecimiento de un exiguo 0,2% sobre todo
la principal razón que explica esta
aceleración de la economía en la
eurozona está la bajada de los precios
de la energía y luego una mejora en el
mercado laboral que ha abatido
Auténticos récords en los últimos meses
en la Unión Europea sin embargo no todos
son buenas noticias porque la inflación
sigue siendo muy alta a pesar de la
bajada de los precios de la energía lo
que preocupa especialmente es la
inflación subyacente es decir la que no
tiene en cuenta ni los alimentos frescos
ni la energía está seguirá muy alta
según las previsiones superará el 6%
esto afectará notablemente al poder
adquisitivo de los hogares pero también
se traduce en un alza de los tipos de
interés para tratar de reducir la
inflación en un 2% tal y como advirtió
recientemente El Banco Central europeo